it's time
to live your ultimate super villain
fantasy
today you're going to unleash your
masterpiece
of mass destruction an antimatter bomb
how would you build it how much damage
would it do
to the planet and how much damage would
it do
to your bank account
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we detonated an antimatter bomb on
earth
okay so before you finalize any plans to
usher in the apocalypse let's see what
we're working with
imagine subatomic particles had an
opposite day that's antimatter
for example anti-electrons also called
positrons are just like electrons except
they have a positive charge instead of a
negative one
antimatter is just matter with its
electrical charge reversed
[Music]
you with me i know i know when do the
explosions come in
when a particle and an antiparticle meet
they will annihilate each other in a big
flash of energy
this usually happens in the form of high
energy gamma ray radiation
this all sounds wonderfully destructive
but
first you have to build it that's
easier said than done i hope you have
steady hands because
your main goal would be to keep
antimatter separated from
normal matter until the bomb is ready to
go off
steady you want to make sure you don't
drop
i'm sorry that was mean if you value
your life and
you want to avoid a premature explosion
you may want to use
something called a penning trap using
the petting trap
antimatter such as positrons will be
trapped inside an electric field
just make sure you keep that trap
powered
if you don't the electric field will
stop working
and all your anti-matter particles would
come into contact with
the container walls which in case you
forgot
is made up of normal matter you know the
rest
but while you are tinkering with the
penning trap
we could run into another problem
even if you managed to pull together all
the antimatter on earth
you would only have 10 nanograms
for perspective if that amount of
antimatter
exploded on your fingertip it would be
as dangerous as lighting a match
okay that's disappointing huh
i really thought that one was gonna
explode
you came here for explosions and you're
going to get them
let's say you went on a shopping trip
around the solar system
and were able to get your hands on half
a kilo of antimatter
think it's gonna be enough this time
well that amount of antimatter is
equivalent
to 19 megatons of tnt
oh yeah now we're talking
so is this antimatter bomb going to be
the doomsday device you wanted
well thankfully we've got a reference
point
the star bomba is the most powerful
nuclear bomb
ever created it also happens to be
as powerful as an anti-matter bomb
containing about 1.1 kilos of antimatter
you uh you might want to stand back when
the antimatter bomb explodes
it will erupt into an enormous fireball
creating a 10 kilometer wide column of
dust
shooting straight up into the sky
next up would be the mushroom cloud
reaching
65 kilometers into the atmosphere
so good news it's going to do some
damage
the bad news is it damaged your bank
account even worse
one of the biggest challenges to
building an antimatter bomb
would be the cost this is because
antimatter is the most expensive
substance
on earth a single gram of antimatter
can set you back over 60 trillion
dollars
60 trillion dollars so
maybe you could find another hobby
besides blowing up the earth
maybe you could use your antimatter
knowledge for
something good what if we could create
anti-gravity well
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]